Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Du hast mich gerade noch beschallt mit Taylor Swift. Du bist großer Fan.
Wie fandest du es?
Ganz gut, ja.
Ich bin kein großer Fan, sondern wenn bei mir ein Spieleabend läuft und ich
überlege, welche Musik kann man denn nebenher dueln lassen?
Stellt sich raus, man lässt Taylor Swift laufen, dann fragen alle,
was ist denn das? Dann sagt man so, Taylor Swift, oh ja, so ne,
die typische André Rieu-artige, das gehören ja alle, ich möchte es nicht hören.
Dann lässt man es trotzdem weiterlaufen und dann kommt es eigentlich immer zu demselben Effekt,
dass man sich erst nicht gestört fühlt durch die Musik und wenn sich die Lieder
dann wiederholen, freut man sich doch auf diese kleinen Nuancen,
die dann so im limbischen System erwartbar, relativ zügig erwartbar werden,
was eben bedeutet, es ist hochgradig durchkalkulierte Musik.
Wir sind geradezu Ratten im Spiel dieser Musikindustrie von Taylor Swift.
Wir funktionieren genau nach Plan als Konsumenten, aber es funktioniert eben trotzdem.
Und sie bringt aber trotzdem diese menschliche Komponente dann bei der Tour
wohl ein. Also es ist nicht der Roboter auf der Bühne, den wir da erleben.
Das ist ganz erstaunlich, um kurz auszuholen. Es gibt ja gerade verschiedene
Touren verschiedener Genres. Metallica sind auf Tour.
Beyonce ist auf Tour, Taylor Swift ist auf Tour. Und wenn man sich so die YouTube-Videos
anschaut, sieht man doch, die Leute wissen jeweils, was sie bekommen.
Weekend zum Beispiel. Die Leute gehen hin, kennen die Musik,
hören dann auch die Musik und sind dann doch enttäuscht, weil der Typ die halbe
Show mit einer Maske rumrennt.
Man sieht so, das ist alles nach Takt, Lichtshow und so weiter.
Und bei Taylor Swift ist doch erstaunlich,
dass man, meine Erfahrung jedenfalls, sehr genau hinschaut bei den YouTube-Videos,
die so von Fans mittlerweile in sehr guter Qualität gemacht werden,
ist das jetzt Seattle Nacht 1, Seattle Nacht 2, weil man doch diese kleinen
Unterschiede sucht, die dann auch da sind.
Und sie hat ja zwischendurch, sie spielt ja 3,5 Stunden.
Und diese kleinen Segmente, wo man nicht genau weiß, was spielt sie denn jetzt,
weil sie es vielleicht selber erst live entscheidet, weil sie wirklich nur Standardlicht
und eine Gitarre oder am Piano sitzt.
Und dadurch ist das so ein Wechselspiel zwischen der Hypershow einfach,
die dann auch diese Erdbeben auslöst. Also wenn Shake It Off und so gespielt wird.
Aber auch diese zweimal-, halb- bis dreiviertelstündigen, kleinen Country-Musicartiken,
wo es auch nicht zu hell ist im Stadion, alle noch mal zurückfallen lassen können
in ihren Sitzen. Es ist ja alles bestuhlt.
Oh, das ist gut, das wär sogar ...
Ja, es ist bis Reihe eins bestuhlt, und ich find's mega. Also,
es ist wirklich unglaublich, wie's mich erreicht, wo ich weiß,
dass ich da sehr anfällig bin, siehe andere Revue und so weiter.
Ich hab übrigens Karten gekauft fürs Astor-Kino, weil da die Sommershows von
André Rieu übertragen wird.
Ja, dann bist du definitiv der Jüngste da, würde ich mal ... Ich glaube, ich auch.
Ja, viel Spaß dabei. Dann vielleicht doch lieber Taylor Swift.
Aber da kommt man ja so schwer an Karten.
Ach so, ja, ich habe allen, die bisher auf Instagram oder Sonstiges so ...
Ich habe Karten für irgendein ... Also, dann die Orte, die anwenden.
Ich habe dann immer geschrieben, falls irgendwas dazwischenkommt,
denk doch zuerst an mich.
Ich möchte niemandem, denn ich bin kein Zwifti.
Jedenfalls muss ich das ehrlicherweise sagen, wenn ich sehe,
wie die Zwiftys abgehen im Stadion. Ich bin kein Zwifty, ich will niemandem
seine Karte wegnehmen, aber falls irgendwo jemand Karten hat,
und es kommt aber was dazwischen, diese Show werde ich nächstes Jahr schon gerne sehen hier in Europa.
Okay, so lange bleibt uns Netflix. Netflix hat mal wieder einen Film parat,
eine Eigenproduktion oder Einkauf, das ist ja auch manchmal gar nicht mehr so genau zu sagen.
Jedenfalls eine Produktion mit deutschen Schauspielern. Kostja Ullmann ist dabei.
Dann sieht man auch noch Ulrich Wickert, nämlich einen verjüngten Ulrich Wickert.
Es geht um ein Verjüngungsprogramm und Ulrich Wickert taucht kurz auf,
dort als verjüngter Nachrichtensprecher und wir hören jetzt mal kurz in diesen Trailer ein.
Er bietet ein Zeitspendenprogramm, das jedes gespendete Lebensjahr großzügig
vergütet. Wie würden sie sich fühlen, man nimmt ihnen ihr Leben weg und gibt es eine Milliardäre?
Ich meine, wenn jemand gar nichts mehr hat außer seine Jugend,
willst du ihn auch noch verbieten davon zu profitieren?
Paradise heißt der Film, eigentlich eine interessante Prämisse,
man kann seine Lebenszeit verkaufen an einen Milliardär,
also man ist 18 Jahre alt, hat kein Geld und sagt sich, gut,
ich verkaufe einen Teil meiner Lebenszeit, sagen wir die 12,
15 Jahre, die man braucht, um so und so viel Millionen zu bekommen und dann
bekommt die dieser Milliardär und die sind dann für immer jung.
Das ist die Prämisse des Films. Ja, es gab einen Film mit dem Titel In Time
mit Justin Timberlake, der sehr gut ist, denn der ist eigentlich ein marxistischer Film.
Dieser Film aber erreicht es überhaupt nicht. Erst einmal fragt man sich hier schon.
Was ist mit der schauspielerei los also das ist das
ja das man man versteht das gar nicht was wie wie
lustlos das aufgesagt ist oder wie dann naja
überzogen hier gespielt wird ich glaube es ist also bei netflix scheint mir
entsteht oder auch auch in vielen was man im deutschen film so sehen kann es
entsteht eigentlich so ein neues bauerntheater nur jetzt im kino ja oder auf
streamingplattformen,
dass man so entweder völlig lustlos was runter leiert, das machen dann die alten
routiniers und die anderen overacten in einer ganz merkwürdigen art und weise,
dass man denkt gut das kennt man doch eigentlich noch so von so soap darstellern
vielleicht, aber doch nicht vom film.
Naja jedenfalls dieser film hat eine interessante grundlage aus der er dann
relativ wenig macht, aber es ist unser thema der vergangenen folge gewesen,
deswegen wollte ich es aufgreifen.
Da haben wir ja darüber gesprochen, wie das ist, wenn man das Leben vorzeitig
verlässt, weil die ökonomische Lage einen dazu treibt.
Und das ist jetzt mal ein bisschen diese Geschichte aus anderer Sicht.
Aber wir werden da im Salon. Nein, nein, ich habe da im Salon dann doch anderes zu empfehlen.
Und ich wurde aber gar nicht für diese Beiträge zum Thema Suizidhilfe kritisiert,
sondern mich erreichten einige böse Nachrichten. Also nicht viele,
aber doch einige böse Nachrichten von der letzten Generation.
Und da will ich erst einmal sagen, ich bin gegen das,
was der Staat tut, wenn er die letzte Generation in dieser Weise verurteilt,
wenn da Leute Hausdurchsuchungen haben, bin ich dagegen.
Ich finde das Anliegen an sich, wir müssen mehr tun, um den Klimawandel zu stoppen, auch richtig.
Bisweilen wurde ich da in der AfD-Nähe oder so gestellt. Meine Kritik war eine
an der Strategie der letzten Generation, weil ich sage, mit dieser Strategie
wird man nichts erreichen.
Im Gegenteil, man wird eher dafür sorgen, dass die Leute,
die zu gewinnen wären für den Klimakampf, nämlich da, wo Klima und die soziale
Frage zusammengehen, diese Leute wird man nicht bekommen, weil die im Stau stehen,
weil die sagen, jetzt kommen auch noch die, die sich da festkleben.
Außerdem halte ich es für idiotisch, und ich wiederhole das wirklich so in dieser
Drastik, zu glauben, dass man den Verkehr in Deutschland blockieren muss,
um klarzumachen, dass wir eine Verkehrswende brauchen.
Eine Verkehrswende, außer in den ganz großen Städten München,
vielleicht noch Frankfurt, ich glaube schon eher kaum Berlin,
aber das war es schon fast, ja.
Eine Verkehrswende wird es geben mit einer besseren Infrastruktur der Öffentlichen, Aber es.
Wird.
Immer Individualverkehr geben müssen. Jetzt ist die Frage, in welchen Autos
wird das gemacht? Sind das E-Mobilitätsautos?
Man hätte schon längst ja ganz andere Autos kreieren können.
Wir wissen, dass Autos müssen nicht 400 PS haben. Das sind alles Diskussionen,
auf die ich mich gerne einlasse.
Aber wer glaubt, dass in einem Land wie Deutschland die Individualmobilität
abgeschafft werden kann,
der kann offenbar keine Landkarten lesen, keine Stadtkarten und hat keinerlei
Ahnung, hat Berlin und München oder Hamburg nie verlassen.
Ich empfehle mal ein Praktikum zu machen, eine Woche bei irgendeiner Familie,
nicht irgendwo auf dem Land, sondern in einer kleineren Stadt.
Und dann kann man die ja mal begleiten, wenn die Kinder zur Schule bringen müssen
oder einkaufen gehen. Und dann versucht man das mal bitte alles dann nicht mit
dem Auto zu machen. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das laufen soll.
Also das ist, und da wird man auch niemals Mehrheiten für gewinnen.
Also da wird man mich auch, der ich absolut dafür bin, dass mehr getan werden
muss, wird man nicht dafür gewinnen. Niemals.
Laut neuesten Zahlen, ich weiß nicht, Politbarometer, Deutschlandtrend,
was auch immer, 60 Prozent unterstützen die Ziele der letzten Generationen.
Was ich irgendwie krass wenig finde.
Und 60 Prozent sagen aber auch, ich finde nicht gut, wie demonstriert wird.
Also es gibt so einen kleinen Disconnect zwischen Inhalt und Form, um es mal so zu sagen.
Und das zeigt ja, dass wir so ein kleines Problem haben bei der Frage,
wie erreichen wir ein Ziel, von dem wir im Tiefen unseres Herzens irgendwie
alle wissen, das wäre für uns alle gut.
Und für die großen Städte habe ich jetzt auch wieder festgestellt und ich führe
ein privilegiertes Leben, in dem ich meistens,
mit dem Fahrrad zu erreichbare Ziele habe, außer es regnet, so komisch,
dann kann ich allerdings aufs Taxi umsteigen, nehme dafür aber Uber,
weil das irgendwie nur ein Drittel des Preises ist, den mich ein Taxi kostet, also sag ich, da sind.
Könnte, könnte woran liegen.
Ja, da sind auch so ein paar Fehlspezifikationen im System, denn ich glaube schon,
dass die ursprüngliche Uber-Idee, dass nämlich viele daran teilnehmen,
also jeder, der in einem Auto sitzt und sagt, ich fahre jetzt von Frankfurt
nach Mainz und sage vorher in der Wolke Bescheid, dass ich diese Strecke absolviere
und vielleicht finden sich bis morgen früh noch zwei andere,
die steigen dann einfach zu. Ich glaube, das hat Sinn.
Aber wie Uber jetzt aufgezogen ist, ist ja ökonomisch so ein bisschen bescheuert.
Und Uber hat ja auch jetzt das allererste Mal überhaupt den ersten Quartalsgewinn
vorgelegt nach über zehn Jahren Existenz. Also ist alles so ein bisschen schräg.
Ich glaube mittlerweile auch, dass der letzte Generation Protest,
deswegen habe ich ja beim letzten Mal auch diese kleine Pointe gebracht,
die sollten einfach jetzt abrupt, aber mit großer Ansage aufhören,
damit alle Leute feststellen, ach so, es wird gar nicht ihr den Verkehr blockieren,
sondern der blockiert sich ja selbst.
Also man kommt ja nicht vorwärts in den großen Städten. Man steht ja wirklich
nur im Stau, wenn man sich bewegen will.
Meine Vermutung ist, wenn man alles noch mal entzerrt, Ziele,
Protestform, Politik und wie auch immer, dass man eigentlich noch mal ein neues
Modell entwickeln muss. Ich sage nur, dass man es entwickeln muss. Ich weiß nicht welches.
Das individuellen Verkehr voranstellt und trotzdem neu ist.
Also nicht auf das Auto gehört mir und ich entscheide, wann ich fahre.
Und ich sage auch niemandem vorher Bescheid, sondern ich blockiere dann einfach
die Straße, wenn ich das will und stelle mich dann irgendwo hin,
weil da einfach zufällig Platz war. So das also das kann nicht die Lösung weiterhin sein.
Irgendwo da in dieser Gemengelage liegt die Lösung.
Aber man muss sich das wirklich noch mal in Ruhe anschauen. Und die letzte Generation,
bei den Aktionen, die ich so sehe, in den Short-Videos der verschiedenen Plattformen,
da herrscht nicht unbedingt gerade bedächtige Ruhe und Diskussionsbereitschaft,
sondern ich sehe immer nur, wie sich Leute an den Haaren über die Straße zerren usw.
Und dann davon wiederum überrascht sind, dass das gefilmt wird und man dann
auch für solche Tätlichkeiten da wirklich vor Gericht kommt und so.
Also sehr viele Leute glauben, ihnen gehört wirklich die Straße.
Und sie dürften jetzt irgendwelche Menschen an den Haaren von der Straße ziehen,
also unglaubliche Zustände.
Das ist dramatisch, was da dann zu sehen ist in diesen Videos.
Aber wir können das jetzt noch 10, 20 Jahre spielen.
Also wir können das jetzt jedes Mal wieder machen und warten,
bis irgendjemand aus dem Truck aussteigt und mit hochrotem Kopf jemanden an
den Haaren von der Straße zieht. Dann können wir das bei Twitter jeden Tag wieder
kommentieren, einordnen.
Dann gibt es wieder die entsprechenden Kommentare. Es ist die Frage, ob wir dafür Zeit haben.
Das zu tun, das würde ich jetzt mal in Zweifel stellen und würde auch noch eins
hinzufügen wollen zu dem Thema Taxi oder Uber.
Ich fahre Taxi, weil ich ja auch gar nicht ein Gerät habe, um das andere zu bestellen.
Aber grundsätzlich bin ich immer Taxi auch gefahren, weil ich dachte gut,
die haben ja den Taxi Schein und die wissen genau, wo es lang geht.
Das ist aber nicht mehr der Fall, denn das wurde ja von Andi Scheuer damals aufgehoben.
Das heißt, man muss nicht mehr diesen sehr aufwändigen Taxi-Schrei machen.
Und ich hatte das Erlebnis ja jetzt in München, dass ich einmal mit dem Taxi
zum Sendlinger Tor musste und der Taxifahrer mich fragte, wo das denn sei und
dann mich bat, das hinzugeben in sein Smartphone.
Und ich dachte, gut Sendlinger Tor, das ist so einer der Hotspots in München.
Und dann in der zweiten Taxifahrt zur Oper wurde ich gefragt,
welche Oper ich meine. Und da hab ich gesagt, naja, die Maximiliansstraße.
Ach ja, dann da unten da. Also auch eine ganz komische Kiste.
Und daraufhin erzählte mir ein anderer Taxifahrer ja, das sei alles aufgelöst
und deswegen würden da jetzt ganz viele fahren, die überhaupt keine Kompetenz haben.
Und deswegen ist der Unterschied jetzt wirklich dann nur noch ein preislicher
zwischen Uber und Taxi und das ist eigentlich sehr schade.
Ja, also dieses Uber-Prinzip, wir haben das letzte Mal über Essensversorgung
im sozial nahen Umfeld gesprochen, Nachbarschaften und so weiter.
Wir brauchen sowas auch für den Verkehr irgendwie. Sehr viele Leute steigen
morgens in ihre Autos und fahren alle parallel dieselbe Strecke, aber jeder für sich.
Und das macht keinen Sinn. Es gab in Amerika lange diese Idee,
eine Autospur nur für Autos, in denen mindestens zwei Leute drin sitzen und so.
Dieses ganze Pooling so ein bisschen anzuvisieren, wie auch immer.
In Uba hat man das ja durchaus so gemacht, aber aus Gründen der Knappheit.
Andere Knappheits, die jetzt auch in der Türkei und so weiter kommen.
Aber Knappheiten können wir natürlich jetzt auch hier erkennen.
Insofern ist das eine Idee. Mir sagten übrigens auch Taxifahrer,
dass der Unterschied jetzt gar nicht mehr so groß ist zwischen dem,
was man bei Uber verdienen kann oder dann mit dem Taxi. Aber es kommt,
glaube ich, sehr auf die Branchen an.
Da wollen wir jetzt nicht im Trüben fischen.
Wir brauchen hier mehr genossenschaftliche, so kleinkollektivistische,
nachbarschaftliche Ideen, denn jedes...
Also alle fünf Meter steht hier ein Auto auf der Straße. Ich war letztens in
Bonn, wahrscheinlich eine meiner erfolgreichsten Instagram-Stories überhaupt.
So viele Herzchen habe ich noch nie bekommen. Ich habe einfach diese Straßenzüge
fotografiert von mitten auf der Straße.
Und du hast ja, das sieht ja aus wie Boston. Also das sind ja die wunderschönsten
Straßen überhaupt, die Deutschland hat in Bonn.
Und dann hast du aber alles volle Autos, Lücken los. Und jedes Mal fährt einer
die ganze Zeit nur im Kreis, um noch die nächste Lücke wieder zu füllen.
Und das ist ein guter Punkt. Denn es ist ja nicht so, dass die Autofahrer Spaß
daran haben. Die sagen ja nicht, ach ist das toll, dass wir jetzt mal hier,
sondern es ist die Alternativlosigkeit.
Es wird so getan, als würde dieses Freiheitsversprechen von Ulf Poschert,
dass er immer artikuliert, wenn es ums Auto geht, als würde das wirklich stimmen.
Das stimmt aber nicht. Das erfährt nicht der normale Autofahrer.
Ja, wenn man Chauffeur vielleicht hat oder so oder den Sportwagen einmal sonntags
rausnimmt, dann mag das sein, dass man da irgendein Freiheitsgefühl hat.
Aber normalerweise denkt man nur auch scheiße, wo kann ich denn hier noch parken
und komme ich da noch rein und...
Also alles in allem.
Es ist nur schlecht.
Die Rush-Hour-Durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit in Köln, Stuttgart,
Frankfurt, Teile von Berlin ist 7 km h oder so.
Jaja.
Also das, was wir gerade als das ist das Nonplusultra und so soll es bitte bleiben,
liebe letzte Generation, ist wirklich erwiesenermaßen nicht die Lösung.
Wir kommen nicht vorwärts.
Und ich will das nochmal aufgreifen, haben wir die Zeit uns damit auseinanderzusetzen?
Wahrscheinlich haben fast alle schon das Interview gehört von Adam Tooth, der war bei Tilo zu Gast.
Drei mal hören.
Mindestens, ja. Und ich hab jetzt aber doch gedacht, ich bring mal Clips mit,
um nochmal zu sagen, wie fantastisch es ist.
Aber ich sag ja, das ist aber jetzt wissenschaftlich notwendig.
Aber was mich als Bürger und beteiligter Bürger… Man muss dazu sagen,
Thilo hat hier den neuen Bericht vom Club of Rome und die sagen selbstverständlich,
wir steuern auf die Katastrophe zu, deswegen brauchen wir die Crows.
Und damit wird Adam Tooze konfrontiert.
Vater eines Kindes, das in diese Zeit hineinwächst, interessiert,
sind Sachen, die tatsächlich geschehen könnten.
Das kann nicht geschehen? Das, was Sie so beschreiben, wie Sie es tun,
wird in dieser Form nicht geschehen.
Nein. Wenn man nicht die politische Mehrheit bestimmen kann und die Machthebel,
die es einem ermöglichen machen
würden, das durchzusetzen, halte ich das einfach für eine leere Floskel.
Und leere Floskeln können wir uns in diesem Moment nicht mehr leisten.
Wir brauchen Sachen, die man tatsächlich umsetzen kann.
Also wenn das das Maß des Möglichen ist – und da haben wir jetzt erlebt,
was mit der Ölheizung in Deutschland los war – und dann kommt jemand mit einem
solchen Text, denke ich, okay, ich weiß nicht, ob ich Zeit habe,
mich mit solchen Sachen abzugeben.
Sehr gut, leere Floskeln. Leere Floskeln ist das Thema unserer Buchbesprechung
heute im Salon, Realität Plus.
Das müssen wir uns – ich werde uns auch gleich nochmal mit anderen Sachen primen. Es gibt...
In der Soziologie die Unterscheidung Semantik und Struktur. Also das Gerede
und dann aber die Realität selbst. Und dann die Frage, welchem Verhältnis steht das zueinander.
Und das hat Tooth hier ganz wunderbar immer herausgehoben, ohne dabei irgendwo
ungeduldig, wütend oder Sonstiges zu werden, was man so für sich selber kennt.
Deswegen ist man ja auch selber kein großer Princeton-Professor,
sondern eben Adam Tooth.
Die Geduld aufzubringen, Leuten zu sagen, Ja.
Schöne, und dann kann man sich's aussuchen, Fanfiction, Verschwörungstheorie,
politischer Wunsch, was auch immer. Es gibt aber eine sehr hohe Distanz zur
strukturellen Entsprechung, dem Korrelat dieses Geredes.
Oder es ist gar nicht vorhanden.
Und dieser Verweis auf, seht doch, wie wir in Deutschland über die Heizung diskutiert haben, ne?
Angesichts der Probleme, die wir da vor uns haben, ist absolut genau der richtige Hinweis gewesen.
Deswegen auch mein Verweis auf, dieses Gespräch bitte dreimal anschauen,
damit man beim zweiten Mal weiß, worauf man sich einlässt und beim dritten Mal
dann auch wirklich bereit ist, zu verstehen, was Adam Tooze einen sagen möchte.
Denn immer häufiger kommt ja dieses, hast du Adam Tooze bei Tilo gesehen?
Wir müssen auch was mit dem machen und so. Und dann kommen ganz viele Redaktionen
so auf. Nein, wir müssen gar nichts mit dem machen. Schaut euch einfach das
Gespräch noch mal an. Da ist die Essenz dessen, was er euch mitteilen möchte, drin.
Und deswegen kann man sich das mehrfach anschauen, ohne immer auf das Neue dann
abzustellen. Nein, Adam Tooze wollte uns zwar sagen, dass wir beim ersten Mal
sicherlich noch nicht so verstehen, wie er es uns sagt.
Trotzdem bin ich sehr dafür, dass Redakteure dieses Interview als Anlass nehmen,
um Adam Tooze einzuladen.
Absolut. Immer besser eher, bevor irgendjemand anders da sitzt.
Und was mir so klar wurde bei diesem Gespräch ist, dass wir im linken,
linksliberalen Aktivismus seit 15 Jahren,
eigentlich laufend leere Floskeln haben. Wenn ich das mal ganz kurz,
gib mir zwei Minuten das zu skizzieren.
Finanzkrise 2008, was waren da dann plötzlich die Debatten?
Ja die Zinsen sind das Problem. Dann fing man an, wie man eigentlich die Welt
entschulden kann. Die Schulden sind ja das große Ding. Da hat Graeber auch sehr
falsch gelegen und da hat sich dann so eine ganze Bewegung Occupy,
Wall Street und so weiter drum gekümmert.
Dann kamen solche Themen wieder auf, wir brauchen regionale Währungen,
um den Zentralbanken zu gehen, also auch so eine Pseudodebatte.
Dann das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen, wo man glaubte, dann würde alles super
werden, wenn wir das nur allen auszahlen.
Nichts ist ferner als das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen, wir kriegen ja nicht
mal hin, dass wir zwei Euro diesen verdammten Mindestlohn anheben und jetzt
ist man da bei diesen bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen.
Leuten sind die immer noch da und man weiß gar nicht, wie soll überhaupt dann
noch eine Volkswirtschaft funktionieren.
Also es ist völlig illusorisch, dann kam mit diesem bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen,
jedenfalls wurden wir wieder mit so einer Debatte totgelabert.
Dann kam Corona, dann hat man gesagt, ach wie toll, die Welt erholt sich.
Jetzt kommen wir mal wieder alle bei uns selbst an.
Was natürlich völliger Unsinn war, weil alles weiter geht und die Industrie
mega Profite eingeheimst hat.
Während man eigentlich eine Boomphase hat, hat man es dann auch versäumt in
einen wirklichen Arbeitskampf einzutreten, hat es versäumt den Mindestlohn sehr
viel früher schon in entsprechende Höhen zu treiben.
Und jetzt in einer Krisensituation plötzlich, da ist es natürlich viel schwieriger, das herzustellen.
Dann hat man diese Debatte plötzlich bekommen mit, was heißt plötzlich,
aber die kam dann sehr laut durch Corona wieder und ist ja bis heute dann da
und auch fortgetragen von letzter Generation und vielen anderen, Degrowth.
Wir haben gerade die Growth, wir haben eine Rezession 0,3 Prozent.
Ist das toll für die Umwelt? Nein, es wird weniger Geld ausgegeben für innovative
Technologien, es werden alle ärmer und die die arm sind werden besonders viel
ärmer, weil die reichen sich davor schützen können.
Die Gross in einem System wo die Herrschaftsverhältnisse so ungleich verteilt
sind, das Vermögen so ungleich verteilt ist, bedeutet das einfach ein ganz ganz
großer Teil der Bevölkerung sehr sehr wenig hat und noch weniger haben wird.
Wie man in anderen Ländern beobachten kann, die kein tolles Wirtschaftswachstum
haben, da gibt es eine reiche Elite und die anderen sind einfach bitter arm und bleiben es auch.
Und so können auch Gesellschaften funktionieren, also diese Staaten brechen
nicht alle völlig in sich zusammen.
Man muss sich dann nur im Klaren sein darüber, dass dann 40,
50 Millionen in wirklich bitterer Armut leben.
Die Growth in einem Weltwirtschaftssystem, das auf Wachstum ausgelegt ist,
auf Globalisierung und darauf, dass jetzt möglicherweise mit neuen Technologien
das ein oder andere verhindert werden kann, damit es noch schlimmer wird,
was das Klima anbelangt.
Dass man da glaubt, man könnte mit einem Minuswachstum, könnte man weiterkommen, ist völlige Idiotie.
Man kann sagen, man muss manches zurückbauen, aber es kann nur so funktionieren,
den man weiter am Wirtschaftswachstum festhält, auch wenn man in einer internationalen
Konkurrenzsituation auch mitspielen will. Also wie stellen die Leute sich das denn vor?
Schotten wir uns dann hier völlig ab und sagen, wir machen jetzt hier einen
Bauernstart oder was und kochen nachmittags Rüben?
Ich bin nicht so ruhig wie Adam Tooze, weil mich das jetzt aufregt,
Seit Jahren werden immer diese ganzen Konzepte diskutiert,
statt einfach mal zu sagen, wie könnte man eine Mehrheit organisieren dafür,
vielleicht sogar in Form von Generalstreik oder was auch immer,
dass der Mindestlohn auf 18 Euro raufgeht.
Das würde die Situation für alle verbessern.
Das würde dafür sorgen, dass auch nicht profitable Geschäftszweige nicht mehr funktionieren würden.
Und dann hätte vielleicht auch Uber ein Problem. Dann würde bei Amazon besser
bezahlt werden oder manche Dinge gibt es dann nicht mehr.
Aber das wäre eine Situation, die für alle ein besseres Leben herstellen würde
und man hätte zugleich auch dann die Möglichkeit zu sagen und wir knüpfen an
diese neue Errungenschaft mit dem Lohn auch etwas Ökologisches,
was müsste getan werden und diese ganzen Arbeitsplätze, die gebraucht werden,
für eine grüne Transformation herzustellen, sind hier sowieso alles Arbeitsplätze.
Die mehr Geld dann einbringen werden. Wir reden ja eigentlich davon von Spitzentechnologien
und so weiter, die entwickelt werden müssen.
Wo ist der Protest für ein Rieseninvestment und all das?
Also ich will jetzt wirklich mal über die ökonomischen Tatsachen sprechen.
Und nicht immer nur solche Ideen haben von, ja mit einem bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen,
wenn dann jeder 1500 bekommt, dann ist das so und so und so.
Oder mit Decreose, dann müssen wir uns alle mal bescheiden.
Ulrike Herrmann zählt die Kalorien für uns ab. Also das ist doch nicht mehr normal.
Also das kann doch nicht sein, dass wir das jetzt immer so weitermachen.
Und dann wundert man sich immer, wenn dann plötzlich so eine Jahresbilanz kommt
und man merkt, ach so, die Konzerne haben jetzt doch noch mal so 30 Prozent plus gemacht.
Haben wir gar nicht mitbekommen, weil wir ja damit beschäftigt waren,
über irgendwelche Unsinnskonzepte nachzudenken,
über irgendwelche Regionalismen und dann versucht man irgendwelche Modelle von
Landwirten in Lateinamerika zu adaptieren für Deutschland, ja also das kann ich nicht ernst nehmen.
So ist es, ich habe dem nichts hinzuzufügen.
Ich will noch ein Clip von Adam Tooze, der mich auch sehr überrascht hat.
Wir sehen ja in Deutschland, wie das mit der Ölheizung prima lief und das ist
die progressivste Regierung, die es in der demokratischen Welt im Moment vermutlich
gibt, in einem größeren wichtigen Land.
Unsere? Die andere Regierung, ja. Nenn mir eine andere. Weiß ich nicht,
aber das ist progressiv bei uns. Ich glaube, das ist die progressivste im Vergleich.
Ach du Scheiße. Nenn mir eine andere. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube nicht,
dass es eine andere gibt.
Deshalb auch das internationale Interesse an dem, was die machen.
Das Habeck-Ministerium wird von vielen Menschen weltweit beobachtet als im Grunde
das leitende Experiment bei der Energiewende.
Das ist vermutlich das einzige wirklich führende nationale Ministerium,
wo man wirklich davon ausgehen kann, dass die bestimmenden Leute wirklich dabei sind.
Das ist in praktisch keinem anderen Land der Welt der Fall.
Also, ja, ich bin auch drüber gestolpert, hab's auch getwittert,
fand's sehr amüsant, stimmt wahrscheinlich auch.
In diesem Moment hat aber noch jemand drunter geschrieben, was ist mit Spanien?
Und ich so, naja, was ist mit Spanien? Also wir erwarten ja gerade einen Rechtsdruck.
Und jetzt wissen wir, es ist so ein Patt.
Wir sehen, was in Amerika los ist, dass jede weitere Anklage gegen Donald Trump
irgendwie als Ach ja, dann will ich doch ihn zum Präsidenten.
Was wir ja nicht verstehen können, dass dann die Hälfte der Gesellschaft so tickt.
Aber wir haben immer noch, auch wenn es nicht groß ist, Dänemark,
Norwegen, Schweden und so weiter, die skandinavischen Länder,
die ja nun doch flächendeckend Wärmepumpen, E-Mobilität und so weiter schon
eingebaut und eingepreist haben.
Haben, was ich dann wieder nicht verstehe.
Ja, Habeck kommt aber von einem anderen, also ich will jetzt hier auch nicht
Habeck verteidigen, aber Habeck muss ja mit einem anderen Status Quo operieren.
Da in den skandinavischen Ländern ist das über längere Zeit dann entwickelt
worden und dann kann man sagen, die haben jetzt mehr erreicht wie wir und er
sagt ja jetzt auch nicht Deutschland ist das sauberste Land der Welt,
ganz im Gegenteil, das führt ja auch aus, wo die Probleme liegen.
Aber Habeck kommt natürlich von einem Status, einem ganz schönen Dreckschleuder,
die er vor sich hat und die versucht er mit seiner Politik etwas sauberer zu
bekommen und in diesem Ansatz, was er da erreichen will, ist ja die progressivste
Form von Politik, die gerade zu finden ist auf diesem Globus.
Treckschleuder ist genau der richtige Begriff, weil man den auf zwei Ebenen,
nämlich Semantik und Struktur einmal sehen muss.
Habeck kommt aus Schleswig-Holstein. Dort weiß jeder,
da weht Wind, da ist Nordsee, da kann man einfach Windräder aufbauen und dann
hat ja Habeck das dort als Landesminister auch so georganisiert,
dass die Leute direkt was von der Windkraft haben.
Dadurch, dass da so direkte Finanzströme sind, haben die auch ein echtes Interesse
daran, welche Turbine werden da verbaut und so weiter.
Und die wissen, okay, eine Turbine sind 10.000 Haushalte. Also da hat man so
eine gewisse Vorstellung davon. Also man hat es strukturell reingebaut bekommen
mit den Nordsee und man weiß darüber Bescheid.
Das Gerede dazu ist da. Und dann kam man in die Bundespolitik, wo es ganz anders läuft.
In Süddeutschland hat man keine Ahnung von den Naturgewalten.
Man lädt sich zwar immer tausend Touristen in seiner Wohnung ein,
die dann irgendwie sich die Berge anschauen sollen, aber man hat selber kein
richtiges Gefühl für Naturgewalten, Sonne und Windkraft.
Und man hat aber gleichzeitig so einen riesigen politisch-semantischen Apparat dagegen gehabt.
Und das ist eben auch eine Dreckschleuder. Also wir haben nicht nur echte Kohlekraftwerke
und so weiter, die das da befeuern, diesen süddeutschen Industriestandort.
Sondern wir haben auch darum so eine semantische Dreckschleuder,
die wirklich alles im Grund und Boden argumentiert hat.
Inklusive, sollen wir nicht mal eine Stromleitung bauen, sodass wir die sieben
Gigawatt Windkraft, die wir vor 15 Jahren da schon hatten, einfach mal mit einer
Steckdose in Süddeutschland, also dieses Südlink, nein, das muss alles unter
die Erde, ich möchte hier nirgendwo einen Strommasten sehen und so weiter.
Weil die Leute keine Ahnung davon hatten, was für eine Power,
um was es da eigentlich geht.
Und mit dieser Dreckschleuder hatte Havik erst recht so gar nicht rechnen können,
weil man in Norddeutschland einfach den Leuten gesagt hat, ja,
diesen Wind, der dich da immer jeden Tag vom Deich puste, den kann man für Energie
nutzen. Ja, liegt auf der Hand, macht Sinn und so. Und dieses Gespräch gab es da nie.
Trotzdem zu Adam Twoes, die Norweger insbesondere, aber auch die Dänen und so.
Ich verstehe immer noch nicht, wieso wir auf dieser semantischen Dreckschleuderebene
kein Diskurs darüber bekommen haben, Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Wie gut diese neue Technik ist, auch nach marktwirtschaftlichen Gesichtspunkten,
also es ist nicht nur um Ökologie geht, sondern dass es auch ökonomisch voll Sinn macht,
Windkraft zu nutzen, Sonnenlicht zu nutzen und dass eine Wärmepumpe sogar in Norwegen,
wo es das halbe Jahr Minusgrade sind, noch funktioniert, weil einfach diese ganzen Prinzipien,
ich weiß natürlich auch nicht genau, wie sie funktioniert, aber diese Entropie
von warmen Molekülen so zu nutzen, dass man selbst bei knapp über 0 Grad noch
seine Wohnung heizen kann mit der Außentemperatur, Das ist doch erstaunlich.
Und dieses Wunder wurde semantisch niemals erzählt, diese Zaubergeschichte.
Das liegt aber auch daran, dass man im aktivistischen Diskurs ganz klar dieses
Verzichts-Narrativ ständig wiederholte und sagt, wenn wir die Transformation
wollen, dann müssen wir alle verzichten.
Und ich sehe auch nicht, warum eine Wärmepumpe ein Verzicht sein sollte,
sondern es ist ja eher was sehr Positives. Also das gilt für die Erneuerbaren
und das gilt auch für E-Mobilität in gewissen Punkten. Ich bin da nicht besonders informiert darüber.
Deswegen will ich mich jetzt hier nicht zu sehr aus dem Fenster lehnen,
dann kriegt man nämlich sehr viele E-Mails, die einem das nochmal sehr genau erklären.
Jedenfalls gibt es sehr viele Möglichkeiten, wie man keine Verzichtsgeschichte
erzählen muss, sondern man kann tatsächlich sagen, ja mit der Ökonomie,
der Renewables, mit all dem ist eigentlich sehr viel zu machen.
Und da wir ja keine besonderen Bodenschätze und all das haben,
sondern eigentlich nur unsere Köpfe, wäre es sinnvoll, wenn wir in diese Richtung gehen.
Also man kann eine ganz andere Geschichte damit erzählen. Das passiert aber
so wenig wenn man auch tatsächlich sagt ja technische Innovation jetzt klingst
du ja schon wie die FDP und hier auch noch mal Adam Tooze.
Aber man kann ja ich meine da noch mit anreizen oder irgendetwas in dieser Art
argumentieren ist ja rein zynisch.
Es geht jetzt hier um die Milliardäre wie können wir die loswerden oder was auch immer.
Wie werden wir den los?
Ich meine, wir, wie wird man... Wir als Öffentlichkeit, als westliche Gesellschaften, als Gesellschaft.
Ich denke nicht, dass es die geringste Chance gibt, dass wir sie loswerden.
Oh Mann. Sorry. Ich meine, warum würde... Ich meine, und haben wir nicht einen
ganzen Haufen anderer Probleme. Wir sollten sie nicht feiern.
Wir sollten uns nicht auf sie verlassen. Ja, aber die sind doch...
Wir sollten von ihnen kein Geld nehmen. Aber die Probleme sind doch mit denen verbunden.
Wir hören, ein Milliardär verbraucht so viel CO2 wie eine Million Menschen.
Was man möglichst tun sollte, ist, in bestimmten Formen des Konsums zu verbieten, dass es bestimmt war.
Ja, man sollte steuern auf Flugzeuge und Schiffer erhöhen, Loch und Löcher,
man sollte zum Teil einfach verbieten, sie sollten ausgeschlossen werden von
den wichtigen Orten, wo sie hinfliegen wollen und hinfahren wollen.
All das, aber das sind politische Maßnahmen, die ungeheuer schwierig sind.
Und da könnte, würde ich gerade noch einhaken, mal Aktivismus noch stattfinden.
Es gab es ja zum Teil jetzt, dass die letzte Generation verhindert hat,
dass Privatschätz abheben. Finde ich richtig.
Können Sie sehr gerne machen. Da trifft es dann die Richtigen.
Verlasse ich mich. Und ich sage es nicht mit Enthusiasmus, sondern ich glaube,
dass der Pfad der Entwicklung hin über technologische Lösungen läuft,
weil wir es politisch, gesellschaftlich nicht hinbekommen werden.
Nicht, weil ich ein Technik-Enthusiast, ein Technik-Vernarrt bin,
sondern ich einfach An diesen Fragen dreht man sich ja immer wieder den Kopfwund.
Da gibt es ja keinen Grund zu glauben, dass wir auf Lösungen kommen.
Technische Innovation.
Ein Verweis noch auf diese Milliardäre und so weiter. Wie funktioniert Politik
in Deutschland? Mike Josef, als er hier in Frankfurt seinen dann erfolgreichen
Bürgermeisterwahlkampf gemacht hat, hat mal auf einen was hingewiesen in so
einem kleineren Gespräch.
Die Kommunen leben von der Gewerbesteuer, die bekommen sie nämlich.
Die Einkommenssteuer wird dann irgendwie über den Bund und so weiter und es
wird dann so verteilt und dann bekommt man auch einen Anteil der Einkommenssteuer,
aber man bekommt vor allem Gewerbesteuer.
Und so sieht dann auch die Politik aus.
Ähm, diese 20 oder 10 Milliarden für Intel, damit Intel noch mal 20 Milliarden
drauflegt. Dann entsteht irgendwas, aber es geht nur um 3.000 Arbeitsplätze.
Mehrere Millionen werden investiert für einen Arbeitsplatz.
Weil das am Ende über die Gewerbesteuer abgerechnet wird. Die Kommune freut
sich auf die Gewerbesteuer, die da anfällt.
Die Einkommenssteuer ist ihr egal. Deswegen ist ihr die Ansiedlung des Unternehmens
wichtig und der Umsatz, der da stattfindet, aber nicht die Anzahl der Leute,
die dafür Umsatz sorgen.
Kapital, also der eine Eigner, Intel, hofiert wird,
da wird der Bundeshaushalt geöffnet, trotz Schuldenbremse, 10 Milliarden,
die müssen sein und so weiter, weil man dann weiß, wenn Intel auch noch 20 Milliarden
hinterher steckt, dann droht uns nicht, dass die irgendwann mal abwandern oder
so, sondern wenn das Ding einmal auf 50 Fußballfeldern gebaut ist,
ist das gebaut, dann haben wir hier 100 Jahre Gewerbesteuer sicher.
Und zwar in einem Ausmaß, wie es ansonsten nur die Teststrecke von Porsche irgendwo
da in Süddeutschland oder so bringt, Nämlich 30.000 Euro pro Nase Einwohner, ja, so was abgerechnet.
Die einzelnen Mitarbeiter, das ist total egal, findet in dieser politischen
Rechnung überhaupt nicht statt.
Also unser ganzes lokales Wirtschafts, sagen wir mal, der politisch-wirtschaftliche
Komplex ist darauf ausgelegt, dass es dem einen Eigner, dem Milliardär gut geht
und dass er bei einem zu Hause ist.
Und deswegen auch, wie bekommen wir Milliardäre los? Ja, gar nicht.
Also es ist quasi einprogrammiert in unserer, beginnend beim Steuersystem und
so weiter, dass wir diesen einen,
und Markt ja noch für 1000 Leute CO2 verbrauchen, dieser eine wird Hof 4.
Für den wird alles gemacht. Arbeitsplätze der Einzelne.
Findet da politisch nicht statt. Und das fand ich damals schon ein guter Hinweis im Wahlkampf,
weil das zum Beispiel für Frankfurt bedeutet, ja, es ist ganz schön,
wenn hier in Frankfurt auch Leute arbeiten und die müssen ja dann irgendwo wohnen,
also siedeln wir die mal irgendwo außerhalb der Stadt an und dann wird der große
Frankfurter Bogen, wer innerhalb von 30 Minuten mit der S-Bahn zum Hauptbahnhof
fahren kann, gehört irgendwie dazu, also er wird dann wohnen für diese Nachbarschaftskommunen
subventioniert und wie und so, also so kleine Programme.
Aber das klappt eben nur, weil Frankfurt sich immer kalkuliert,
Wir kriegen so und so viel Gewerbesteuer und dann am Jahresende stellen sie
fest, ah, es waren doch 500 Millionen mehr.
Und diese Kalkulation, dieses Budget, das macht den Unterschied bei der Gestaltung
der Stadt. Das ist Gewerbesteuer.
Die Milliardäre müssen in Frankfurt investieren, die brauchen wir hier,
die Arbeitskräfte nicht.
Und da kann man dann, also wenn jetzt in dieser CO2-Rechnung man sagen würde,
ja, ein Milliardär wiegt so eine Million Menschen auf, okay,
dann kann man vielleicht irgendwie ins Nachdenken.
Aber solange ein Milliardär so tausend, zehntausend Menschen aufwägt,
ist das einfach, also das ist so hart gekodet sozusagen.
Das ist ein Problem, aber nicht unser Hauptproblem und ist auch,
weil es so gekodet ist, wie du es gerade skizziert hast, sehr schwierig.
Es gibt gar keine Mittel gegen Milliardäre.
Also die werden wir nicht in dieser Weise los, die werden wir dann,
wir können gewisse Dinge einfach grundsätzlich verbieten, dass die nicht mehr
möglich sind in Deutschland, dass man das und das nicht mehr darf,
wie man auch jetzt nicht mit dem Panzer privat durch die Gegend fahren darf.
Darf. So kann man auch andere Dinge dann möglicherweise verbieten,
aber das ist ein langer Schritt, ein langer Weg. Aber die Frage ist auch,
ob man damit genau das erreichen will jetzt, worum es ja primär gehen sollte,
nämlich diese Transformation.
Und man darf sich dabei auch des Populismus bedienen, sagt Thoese.
Dass es möglich wäre, eine populistische Politik um um diese Ungleichheit zu
mobilisieren. Das ist populistisch. Und schon mal in ungutem Sinne.
Für mich ist Populismus ein analytischer Begriff, also diese zentristische Rede
von irgendwelchen Leuten als Populisten, die man als solche dann nicht...
Populisten sind im Grunde ja eine Form der demokratischen Politik,
unter bestimmten Vorzeichen, unter bestimmten Prämissen und dazu gehört unter
anderem die Mobilisierung des Volkes gegen die Minderheit, das Volk gegen die Elite, wir gegen sie.
Und das ist ein sehr mächtiges politisches Mittel und durchaus kreativ und absolut
historisch bedingt ein zentrales Element in jeder Umverteilungspolitik,
da sollte man mit ernst machen.
Aber ich meine, historisch gesehen ist ja eines der großen Rätsel der Demokratie-Geschichte,
dass das nicht ein längerfristig in meisten Ländern ein Läufer gewesen ist.
Das war ja der Albtraum der Konservatisen, der Aristokratie im 19.
Jahrhundert. Wenn es ein allgemeines Wahlrecht gibt, dann kommt es unmittelbar zur Enteignung.
Und das Erfolg ihrer Geschichte, ihr Erfolgsrezept seit dem 19.
Jahrhundert ist, dass sie dem immer wieder entgangen sind.
Ja, zieht sich ja bis zur Corona-Krise. Alle Betriebe werden geschlossen,
aber die Mieten werden gezahlt.
Also da ist dieses Hardcoding von Eigentumsrechte und umso mehr Eigentum,
umso wichtiger, umso fester verankert in den Verfassungen und Grundgesetzen
und so weiter. Das ist klar.
Das, was er hier sagt und ich möchte mich an dieser Stelle zum sechsten Mal
als Populismusbeauftragter der Grünen Partei bewerben. Ich hoffe,
irgendwann kommt das Angebot, dass ich das dann auch mal antreten kann, diese Stelle.
Natürlich mit Hilfe der Podcast-Hörer und so weiter, denn dann braucht man ja viele Ideen.
Also dieser Hinweis, den er da gemacht hat, der ist natürlich gar nicht zu dramatisieren
oder irgendwie zu kritisieren,
denn so wie man vorher sagt, eine Semantik, und du hast es ja eben alles mal
aufgeschlüsselt, aufgezählt, eine Semantik, die nicht an die Struktur gekoppelt
ist, brauchen wir nicht, die Zeitverschwendung,
Eine Semantik, die an die Struktur angekoppelt ist, brauchen wir.
Und nur weil wir sie als Populismus deklarieren, weil sie, keine Ahnung,
dann doch mal Effekte zeigt oder ein bisschen abweicht von den von der Struktur
abgekoppelten, viel schöneren Ideen, und so weiter.
Weil Anne Will und Norbert Röttgen dann mal Angst bekommen in ihrer Talkshow.
Genau. Also diese Art der Semantik brauchen wir. Davon haben wir aber zu wenig.
Und deswegen ist dieser Verweis auf Populismus natürlich genau richtig.
Wir brauchen diesen Populismus.
Und was hast du zu diesem Tweet gesagt, den ich hier dir einblende?
Ich lese ihn mal vor. Er stammt von Kai Wegner, er ist der regierende Bürgermeister von Berlin, CDU.
Und er schreibt gestern, die Schuldenbremse darf keine Zukunftsbremse sein.
Als CDU sollten wir den Mut haben, neu zu denken. Wir sollten auch den Ökonomen
zuhören, die Kredite nicht per se verteufeln.
Es geht um Investitionen in krisenhaften Zeiten. Es geht um klare Tilgungspläne.
Schulden sind kein Selbstzweck. Sie müssen auf lange Sicht einen Mehrwert haben,
so wie es bei jeder Familie ist, die einen Hauskredit aufnimmt.
Unser Land hat so viel aufzuholen.
Wir können jetzt investieren oder der gesamten Infrastruktur weiter beim Bröckeln
zuschauen. Und dem Redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland sagte er noch,
dass er so langsam den Eindruck bekomme, dass Lindner zum Totengräber der deutschen Industrie wird.
Jo, das ist natürlich ein, ich will nicht sagen Schulterschluss,
sondern die haben sie ja nicht die Schultern geschlossen.
Es wird viel abgesprochen in der Politik, bevor es öffentlich diskutiert wird,
aber Kai Wegner hat sicherlich nicht mit Robert Habeck davor telefoniert.
Trotzdem ist die Schussrichtung klar. Edmund Tewes hat ja darauf verwiesen,
auch im Gespräch mit Thilo nochmal, dass es ja unglaublich ist,
dass der deutsche Finanzminister in der FAZ unter fremden Federn schreibt.
Er schreibt unter seinem Namen aber eben einen Gastbeitrag in der FAZ,
in dem er noch mal darauf hinweist, dass aus Schulden noch nie was Positives
erwachsen ist. Wo man sich fragt, nein, genau das Gegenteil ist wahr.
Unsere Marktwirtschaft, deswegen ja das Wachstumsprinzip so wichtig,
braucht Anschubinvestitionen.
Man verlagert den Ertrag in die Zukunft und lässt sich das aber bezahlen und
dafür sind die Banken da und die machen das dann. Allen voran die Zentralbanken.
Und dass Kai Wigner hier jetzt so scharf gegen Christian Lindner schießt.
Aber eben auch gegen die CDU. Mhm. Weil Christian Lindner ja das konservative
Erbe der CDU antreten möchte, das gerade durch Merz und Lindemann besonders
hervorgehoben wird im Sinne von Lindner macht's richtig und so weiter.
Finde ich wirklich erstaunlich. Das ist jetzt dieses dreidimensionale Schach, was da gespielt wird.
Marc Schieritz von der Zeit hat einfach drüber getwittert, möchte Kai Wegner
jetzt Bundeskanzler werden. Möglicherweise. Also das bringt er sich jetzt ins
Rennen für nächstes Jahr gegen Wüst und Söder.
Ich glaube jedoch, wir machen es uns zu einfach, wenn wir immer nur sagen,
es ist Lindner und die FDP.
Ich glaube schon, dass es sehr viele konservative, ordoliberale Kräfte sowohl
bei den Grünen, als auch bei SPD-Regierenden
gibt, die weiterhin an der Schuldenbremse festhalten wollen.
Die manchmal dann sagen, es ist ein bisschen schade, dass wir da und dort nicht mehr Geld haben.
Aber an sich wollen sie nicht den Regime change.
Und es ist auch interessant, dass in den einzelnen Bundesländern immer wieder
Regierungen von der Opposition jeweils verklagt werden, wenn die Schuldenbremse
nicht eingehalten wird.
Dann gibt es immer wieder da Prozesse, hier auch in Hessen. Und das ist dann
durchaus die Opposition, eine Mitte-Links-Opposition.
Und die schießt dann gegen die CDU und umgekehrt. Wenn die CDU und die Opposition ist anders.
Das ist kein einheitliches Lager da.
Und ich bekomme auch immer wieder hier übrigens auch von unserem Publikum über
Instagram irgendwelche Äußerungen zu MMT von Grünen geschickt,
wo einem auch Hören und Sehen vergeht, wo man sagen kann, gut,
die haben wohl auch ein bisschen viel Hans-Werner-Sinn rezipiert.
Also das ist sehr erstaunlich, dieser...
Dieser Schritt, den Kai Wegner hier macht. Ich würde aber tatsächlich sagen,
wir müssen aufpassen, dass wir nicht zu sehr das mitspielen,
was SPD und Grüne wollen, nämlich zu sagen, ja, wir sind eigentlich die Guten,
aber leider haben wir diesen Christian Lindner rein.
Ich befürchte, ohne die FDP würde es nicht viel besser aussehen.
Ich glaube ja sowieso inzwischen daran, man kann relativ gut linke Politik umsetzen,
indem man eine starke linke Opposition hat und die CDU an der Regierung.
Ja, das ist ja die Lehre aus vielen Jahren Atomkraft.
Nein, danke. Brauchte man dann Merkel für, um die Wehrpflicht auszusetzen auch.
Also um diese Gemengelage hier nochmal aufzugreifen. Die Schuldenbremse darf
keine Zukunftsbremse sein. Für wen? Für das Land.
Die Milliardäre, von denen Thilo ja vorher sprach und den Diskurs,
den er dem Tuesday so wegwischen wollte.
Den Milliardären ist ja egal, wenn in Deutschland 80 Millionen Menschen leben,
ob 20 Millionen davon in Armut leben oder nicht.
Und man muss sich das auch nochmal kommunalpolitisch vorstellen,
Frankfurt hat ein Gewerbesteuer-Überaufkommen von 500 Millionen Euro.
Also 500 Millionen Euro mehr, als der im Budget der Stadt vorgesehen ist, fließen da auf.
Jetzt ist die Stadt aber auch dafür zuständig, die Grundversorgung Hartz IV
und so weiter zu bezahlen.
Was bedeutet bei irgendwie einem Hartz-IV-Satz von 4000 Euro oder so,
die Stadt Frankfurt könnte allein mit dem, was sie über die eigene Kalkulation
an Gewerbesteuer bekommt, Hunderttausende der 700.000,
Einwohner, also Hunderttausende, Einfach das grundlegende Leben bezahlen nach deutschem Recht.
So wenig wichtig sind arme Menschen in Deutschland.
Man braucht dafür nicht mal in den eigenen Haushalt zu gehen,
sondern alleine das zusätzliche, unerwartete Aufkommen der Gewerbesteuer würde
ausreichen, um ein Viertel der Stadt durch die Armut zu bringen.
Ohne dass irgendein Gericht sagen würde, da zahlen sie aber zu wenig oder so,
denn der Hartz-IV-Satz ist nun mal wie er ist, bei 400 Euro plus ein bisschen Miete und so.
In der Hinsicht dieser Verweis auf die Schuldenbremse, die ja nur garantiert,
dass Investitionen, die stattfinden, privater Natur sind.
Die Leute auch noch mal bei Clara Geiwitz nachgefragt haben,
werden sie jetzt mal langsam öffentlich bauen, wo doch sonst niemand baut? Und sie so, ne.
Heißt ja nur die wenigen Häuser, die noch gebaut werden, werden privat finanziert.
Also die Renditen, die da auflaufen, inklusive allen Zinslastproblemen und so
weiter, werden auch privat eingestrichen.
Statt dass jetzt einfach der Staat da auftritt und sagt, naja,
uns geht es ja nicht ums Plus Minus. Wir wollen einfach nur,
dass ihr wohnt. Nein, diese Stoltenbremse blockiert genau sowas.
Aber klar, Hageibets wäre jetzt zum Beispiel auch ein toller Fall.
Sie könnte ja zum Beispiel ökologisch korrekt bauen lassen.
Also kleiner Tipp an die letzte Generation. Ich weiß, dass uns einige hier zuhören
von der letzten Generation und vor allem auch sehr viele Sympathisanten.
Und da mal ein kleiner Tipp, die hat ja auch ein Ministerium.
Ja, und vor allem sollte es ihr egal sein, was es am Ende kostet,
solange natürlich ökonomisch vernünftig kalkuliert wird.
Also ja, die Baukosten haben sich halt mal verdoppelt in den letzten zehn Jahren.
Das heißt, nur weil der Staat jetzt finanziert, sollte man nicht nochmal eine
Verdopplung rein provozieren, um da Geld abfließen zu lassen.
Das haben wir ja gesehen beim Wohnungsbautag, wie Habeck da stand vor den Leuten
und meinte, Seien Sie ehrlich mit uns, wenn Sie eh schon nach dem,
was wir gerade noch subventionieren, als Standard bauen.
Dann ist das künftig Standard und nicht mehr zu subventionieren.
Also diese kleinen Bittreden waren ja alle da.
Aber Schuldenbremse, also das, gegen was sich Kai Wegner hier richtet,
ist, und Kai Wegner bleibt für mich einer der unterirdischsten Politiker,
nach dem, was ich jetzt gesehen habe.
Aber zumindest dieser Spruch der Schuldenbremse erzielt auf die Reichen und
Superreichen, die private Investitionen noch machen können, denen 20,
30 Prozent der Gesellschaft einfach egal sein kann.
So, weil die Kommunen fangen jetzt dann schon irgendwie auf und so weiter und
so fort. Und gegen die richtet sich jetzt sogar jemand von der CDU,
weil er sagt, geht vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit.
Richtet er sich gegen sie oder sagt er einfach, wir müssen sehen,
dass wir die deutsche Industrie wieder in Gang bekommen und davon profitieren auch die Milliardäre.
Also das eine stieß das andere nicht aus. Ich hatte ja schon immer mal wieder gesagt,
wenn man die zwei Lektüren Handelsblatt und junge Welt zusammenlegt,
dann ist man manchmal über Parallelen doch ganz erstaunt, wenn die einen den
anderen in dem Sinne zustimmen, dass man sagt, ja die deutsche Industrie fahren wir so gegen die Wand.
Und da, glaube ich, ist das einfach ein altes CDU-Thema, dass man jetzt neu
beantworten muss, wie das ja in der beiden Administration auch geschehen ist.
In der beiden Administration sind ja nun auch jetzt sehr viele Köpfe,
die entweder ihren Grundsätzen untreu werden, aber vor allem sind es neue Köpfe,
die sagen, jetzt funktioniert Industriepolitik gut und es geht nicht mehr mit
dem neoliberalen Paradigma.
Und das traue ich durchaus auch CDU-Leuten zu. Die CDU ist ja auch über Jahrzehnte
so erfolgreich gewesen, weil sie durchaus verstanden hat, dass Konservatismus
meint sich anzupassen an Situationen.
Und das kann sein, dass sie das eher machen als gewisse Dogmatiker.
Also ich will auch nicht sagen per se Schuldenbremse und so weiter.
Schuldenbremse hat selbst Christian Lindner mal aufgebrochen,
um zum Beispiel 10 Milliarden Aktien Rente zu finanzieren.
In der Hinsicht man muss immer nochmal auf die Details schauen.
Haushalt, Militär, ja.
Gut, Kai Wegner. Erstaunlich. Ist ja trotzdem eine Überraschung.
Sollen wir in den Salon schreiten?
Ich habe noch zwei Clips, die hören wir aber erst direkt, bevor wir in den Salon
gehen, damit die frisch sind.
Wir sagen noch mal, was wir heute lesen werden. Wir werden zwei Bücher parallel besprechen.
Und zwar einmal von Joachim Bauer. Realitätsverlust, wie KI und virtuelle Welten
von uns Besitz ergreifen und die Menschlichkeit bedrohen.
Das Buch antwortet quasi auf das viel umfangreichere Buch. David J.
Chalmers hat es geschrieben, Realität plus virtuelle Welten und die Probleme
der Philosophie. Es ist ein Bestseller, ein philosophischer weltweit.
Ein Buch, über das alle diskutieren, wir auch. Es ist ein Buch,
das im Silicon Valley rauf und runter gelesen wird. Wir werden uns heute sicher
die naive Frage stellen, warum eigentlich?
Das wird, glaube ich, eine spannende Diskussion. Dann habe ich ganz viel Literatur
mitgebracht. Ich dachte, wir haben es mit dem Sommer zu tun.
Die Leute haben viel Zeit, um Literarisches zu lesen.
Einmal ein Buch, ein Stundenbuch der Liebe. Über eine Liebe,
die über fünf Jahrzehnte dauert. Dann ist der Mann sehr krank und die Frau pflegt den Mann.
Was bedeutet das eigentlich? die ihm noch da ist. Es ist ein unfassbares Buch
von Helga Schubert, über das ich sprechen muss.
Dann Michelle Wellbeck, ich hatte schon angekündigt, hat bei irgendeinem Porno
mitgewirkt und versucht, sich hier zurechtzuwerken, hat einen merkwürdigen Vertrag
unterschrieben. Ich verspreche, ich lese die böseste Stelle aus diesem Buch
vor. Sie ist wirklich ganz, ganz abgründig.
Wir hatten über Suizidhilfe gesprochen. Ich bekam durch eine Lektüre eines anderen Wellback-Textes,
plötzlich eine Inspiration zu einer Science-Fiction-Story, die über 50 Jahre
alt ist, von dem Autor, der auch I am Legend geschrieben hat.
Und da diese Geschichte habe ich mir antiquarisch besorgt.
Und ich muss sie unbedingt vorstellen, denn sie ist ganz grandios.
Außerdem noch ein Text über das, was wir jetzt in den Blick nehmen sollen.
Nämlich jetzt nicht immer so, ja, wir müssen den Verkehr lahmlegen und dann
haben wir das Klima gerettet, Sondern was tut sich eigentlich zum Beispiel bei
den Banken mit der Kreditvergabe?
Wie ist die an Ökologie gekoppelt? Ein Artikel aus dem Handelsblatt.
Und um die Filmkritik steht es nicht gut und zwar weltweit nicht.
Stattdessen sind überall Influencer auf den Filmpremieren.
Und da muss ich auch nochmal einen kurzen Rennt loslassen. Was hast du uns mitgebracht?
Sehr gut. Ich will nur kurz sagen, ich habe letztens einen Film abgebrochen,
auf den ich mich eigentlich gefreut hatte. Ich dachte mir, heute Abend nehme
ich mir die Zeit, Dieser Guardians of the Galaxy 3.
Ich habe nach anderthalb Stunden nicht mehr verstanden, warum mich das irgendwie
interessieren sollte, was da abläuft. Das ist mir noch nie passiert.
Und ich gucke auch wirklich häufig nur wegen der Bilder und der Musik und so weiter.
Aber das war wirklich so Schrott. Also ich konnte es gar nicht glauben.
Da hätte ich auch als Filmkritiker einfach gesagt, es gibt nichts zu sagen. Es ist einfach nur blöd.
Ganz schräg. Gut, also ich lese, ich habe nur drei weitere Texte mit,
denn ich dachte, wir lesen zwei Bücher und drei und dann jeder fünf,
aber du scheinst sieben Texte dabei. Okay, gut.
Also zum einen das OMR, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man es da nennt,
Netzwerk oder was auch immer, die haben so ein Fifty-Fifty, was ja so ein bisschen
auf Gleichstellung und so weiter.
Frauenkarriere und Kinder, sie nennen es eine große Studie,
aber es ist nur eine kleine Befragung von 600 Frauen, die allerdings noch mal
einen Kern heraushebt, der hier wieder mal nur so versteckt wird,
den ich aber noch mal extrem betonen möchte.
Es gibt keinen Gender Pay Gap per se, sondern es gibt eine Child Penalty.
Erst wenn die Kinder ins Spiel kommen werden, die Frauen, dann aber radikal
benachteiligt. Das wird da zumindest in den Zahlen noch mal gut deutlich.
Was ist los mit der Atlantik-Zirkulation?
Wir hören ja gerade, es ist der heißeste Juli ever gewesen auf der Erde.
Trotzdem sitzen wir seit zwei Wochen im Regen. Wie passt das zusammen?
Wir in Europa haben wirklich so eine besondere Situation.
Es ist unglaublich, ich konnte es gar nicht glauben. Aber Stefan Rahmstorf hat
es für Spektrum der Wissenschaften noch mal in zehn Punkten aufgeschlüsselt.
Sodass ich auch denke, okay, muss man den Fokus dann auch noch mal verlegen.
Und als Drittes, die New York Times hinreisende, hervorragende,
sensationelle Weise aufgearbeitet, nämlich einfach visuell.
Das ist nur kurz für den Salon interessant. Der Text ist nicht besonders lang,
aber es werden nochmal die wirklichen zentralen Eckpunkte, auch wie ich sie
besprach, global aufgeschlüsselt.
Und dann kann man an so kleinen Skibereglern mal richtig sehen und fühlen,
wie die ganze Welt einfach ins Alter kippt.
Also was es einfach bedeutet, wenn aus 24 Prozent in dem Rentenalter so 40 Prozent
werden und wie das unterschiedlich auf der Welt verteilt ist.
Auch nochmal in diesem kleinen historischen Vergleich, was haben wir in Europa
eigentlich für eine Entwicklung hinter uns, die letzten 100 Jahre und warum
eigentlich und was steht jetzt Afrika bevor und so. Also da kann man das mal richtig fühlen.
Da ist auch fast egal, wenn man kein Englisch kann, man braucht nur diese Schieberegler
sich mal anschauen und dann kriegt man ein richtiges Gefühl dafür,
dass das wirklich entweder auf Augenhöhe mit dem Klimawandel oder ihn sogar
noch übertreffend ein wirklich menschengemachtes.
Sagen wir mal, Herausforderung ist, vor der wir da stehen. So, und nun zwei Clips.
A. Dadurch spielst du jetzt doch schon? B.
Ich spiele sie jetzt, bevor wir in den Salon gehen, denn ich möchte einfach auf… A.
Ok, dann lass uns doch gerade sagen, wie man in den Salon kommt.
Man kann uns, also in diese andere Realität, könnte man ja vielleicht auch sagen,
Um gleich bei dem Buch zu bleiben, man kann uns in diese andere Realität folgen über Apple.
Dort ist der Salon buchbar. Er ist buchbar über Patreon.
Was wir aber präferieren ist Steady. Das kann man über die Steady Seite machen.
Das kann man über neu20er.de.
Da ist ein Button, wie man zu Steady kommt oder auch, wenn der Podcast über
Spotify gehört wird, dann kann man auch dort anklicken und kommt dann zur Steady
Seite. Das Abo kostet ab 2,50 Euro.
Das ist auch die einzige Möglichkeit, mit der man diesen Podcast unterstützen
kann. Also wer vielleicht gar nicht so viel Interesse am Salon hat,
aber an der Unterstützung des Podcasts kann das machen. Im Salon,
weil das auch manchmal gefragt wird, wie lange sprechen wir?
Zwei, drei Stunden werden es sicherlich werden. Auch dieses Mal und so ist es eigentlich immer.
Und man kann den Salon auch nach wie vor verschenken, wenn man möchte.
Genau, man kann ihn verschenken. Der Button ist auf der Seite.
Auf die Seite kommt man über neuezwanziger.de und dann einfach dem goldenen
Neue Zwanziger Button da folgen.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal über Steady so reden, dass wir noch mal betonen,
wir sind überhaupt in gar keinem besonderen Verhältnis zu Steady,
sondern wir nutzen die ganz einfach, weil wir den Service als sehr praktisch sehen.
Wir sind dort ein ganz normaler Kunde, der einfach ein Angebot macht.
Das heißt, wir operieren nach denselben Gesichtspunkten wie jeder andere,
denn diese Empfehlung könnte man ja auch mal machen. Mir fehlt's ja an...
Etwas klügeren Podcast. Ich finde ja, und keine Ahnung, wenn sich jemand die
Zeit nimmt, was zu lesen oder so, dann ist das ja auch durchaus verdientermaßen zu bezahlen.
Und ich würde mich sehr freuen, wenn es ein paar kluge Angebote gäbe.
Also werdet nicht nur bei uns Steady-Hörend-Kunde, sondern überlegt euch doch auch mal,
aber nicht auch mal bei Steady oder woanders, aber mal so ein bisschen die Flughöhe
anhebt, dadurch, dass die Möglichkeiten bestehen, sich dafür auch bezahlen zu lassen.
Also dieser kleine Werbeblock sei ja auch mal gemacht.
Wir haben von Anfang an einfach nur Steady genutzt. Wir nutzen das auch heute.
Wir telefonieren einmal im Jahr mit denen, um nur zu gucken,
dass das alles glatt läuft. Und deren Sicht sowieso mal ein Plädoyer für diese
Art unabhängigen, irgendwas kreativer arbeiten und so zu machen.
Ja, jenseits der großen Konzernstrukturen und all dem, was da dran hängt. Jetzt deine zwei Clips.
Ja, also wer einen Podcast macht, muss nicht in irgendeinem Studio rennen oder
so und sich dort ein Mikro geben lassen, sondern das kann man wirklich alles selber machen.
So, jetzt meine zwei Clips. Wir haben ein Buch vor uns, das uns auf 600 Seiten
sagen möchte, man kann eigentlich alles ausrechnen.
Das menschliche Gehirn? Na ja, da wartet man noch ein bisschen.
Irgendwann kommen ja die Quanten oder dann die Quanten-Gravitationscomputer
und dann ist das schon alles zu machen.
Jetzt habe ich diese Woche Podcast gehört. Zum einen Raumzeit,
zum anderen Methodisch Inkorrekt. Also zwei sehr wissenschaftliche Podcasts.
Und dann würde man auch noch mal, diese Unterscheidung mache ich selten so,
aber in dem Falle muss ich sie noch mal machen.
Ja, es gibt Wissenschaft, die braucht Mathematik und da muss die Gleichung auch
aufgehen. Da kann man man sich nicht einfach irgendwas ausdenken wie der Schalmers
in seinem Büro oder so, sondern da muss am Ende auf der anderen Seite des Istgleiches
etwas stehen, ansonsten funktioniert nämlich die Maschine nicht.
Jetzt war Tim Brittler für den Raumzeit-Podcast beim CERN und hat sich da mal
diese großen Teilchenbeschleuniger und so weiter erklären lassen,
weil da gibt es irgendwie so neue Sensoren, man kann irgendwas Neues mit Protonen
machen, wie auch immer, kann man sich dann anhören in der letzten Folge.
Und sie kommen so ganz nebenbei auf die Frage, warum macht man das eigentlich
als experimentelle Physik. Kann man sie einfach ausrechnen?
Ich meine, Teilchen, also drei kleine Elementarteilchen stoßen auf was anderes.
Kann man das nicht simulieren? Warum muss denn das in echt gemacht werden?
Und die Antwort ist irgendwie naheliegend, aber sie ist besonders gut illustriert, finde ich.
Denn hier wird mal ganz kurz erklärt in so einem Mini-Exkurs,
wo es schon scheitert bei der Sachen, bei der Frage mathematische Prognose.
Da gibt es unterschiedliche Meinungen. Wir versuchen das,
wie gesagt, über fundamentale Teilchenwechselwirkungen zu beschreiben,
aber selbst wenn man diese Wechselwirkungen nicht beliebig genau kennt,
könnte niemand ausrechnen, welche Formation eine Schneeflocke macht,
wenn man also Systeme hat, die aus sehr vielen Teilchen bestehen.
Prinzipiell kann man das machen, es gelingt aber keinem, weil dann gibt es eben
kollektive Phänomene, die nicht immer aus den fundamentalen...
Oder anders ausgedrückt, Europa braucht unbedingt ein Schneeflockenformungsforschungszentrum.
Ich will das nicht ins lächerliche ziehen, aber es gibt auch emergente Phänomene,
auch Alice beschäftigt sich damit, vielleicht kommen wir da noch später drauf,
die man eben nicht so einfach aus den fundamentalen Wechselwirkungen herlösen
kann. Alles nicht so einfach.
So, die Oppenheimerische Trinity-Bombe musste wirklich mal gezündet werden,
denn man kommt nur so weit mit Physik oder mit Theorie, sagt er ja mehrfach in dem Film.
Wir sind nicht mal in der Lage, eine Schnieflocke zu berechnen,
und zwar nicht, weil uns die Rechenleistung fehlt, sondern weil wir einfach
verstanden haben, es gibt prinzipielle Hürden, wenn so und so viele noch so
gut verstandene Einzelabläufe aufeinandertreffen, kommen einfach emergente Phänomene hinzu,
die es uns prinzipiell verunmöglichen, angefangen bei der Formation einer Schneeflocke.
So, Schneeflocke ist einfach nur ein Tropfen Wasser, der halt mit Luft und so
und Temperatur zu tun hat.
Kann man nicht berechnen. Ich werde nachher wahrscheinlich häufiger auf die
Schneeflocke zu sprechen kommen, wenn mal wieder irgendeine fantastische Idee von Schalmers kommt.
Zweitens, eine Schneeflocke. Wie groß ist eigentlich eine Schneeflocke?
Sehr klar. Also um sie überhaupt zu sehen, braucht man schon ein Mikroskop.
Das heißt, selbst bei mikroskopischen Sachen wird es unglaublich schwer.
Schneeflocken bestehen aus Wasser. Jetzt eine Frage, die ist total albern.
Ich stelle sie dir stellvertretend. Alle Hörer können jetzt kurz mitdenken.
Wie groß ist eigentlich ein Liter Wasser?
Da kann man jetzt nur dumm drauf antworten.
Genau, man kann nur absolut dumm drauf antworten und die Antwort wird euch gleich alle überraschen.
Wasser, ein Liter Wasser, besteht ja aus sehr vielen Wassermolekülen.
Die sind irgendwie in einem Verhältnis, also in einem Dritterpack sind sie ein bisschen gestapelt.
Wenn sie so im Waschbecken sind, sind sie sehr ausgebreitet und so weiter und
so fort. Verschiedene Formen.
Angenommen, nur mal im Kopf jetzt theoretisch, denn physikalisch ist es ja unmöglich.
Aber angenommen, man würde jetzt das Wasser mal aufreihen.
Die Moleküle wirklich nur in einer Reihe liegen.
Wie viele H2O-Moleküle sind denn so im Liter Wasser drin?
Wie groß sind die? Alle in einer Reihe. Wie lang wäre denn diese Reihe von einem
Liter Wasser? 1 Liter Wasser. Jetzt können wir wieder kurz alle überlegen,
okay, 1 Liter Wasser besteht aus so und so vielen Molekülen H2O,
die alle mal wirklich in eine Reihe.
Wie lang wäre das? Also wenn wir jetzt die Oberfläche von Wasser prognostizieren
wollten, wie sie sich verhält, müssten wir irgendwie alle diese Moleküle in
unsere Rechnung einbauen.
Wie viele müssten wir da eigentlich einbauen? Wie groß wäre eigentlich diese Gleichung so?
Bei methodisch inkorrekt sind Sie das mal kurz durchgegangen.
Ein Liter Wasser aufgereiht, der Länge nach. Wie lang ist das?
Genau, ich habe es natürlich vorher auch schon mal ausgerechnet,
um die genaue Zahl zu haben.
In Kilometern jetzt, 9,2, sagen wir mal, 9,2 Billionen Kilometer.
Was? Jetzt sagt man so, okay, Billionen Kilometer, das sagt mir ja gar nichts.
Ne, mir auch nicht. Da hat man natürlich kein Gefühl mehr. Gibt es nicht irgendeine
etwas handlichere Größe, die mir das beschreibt?
Welch kosmischer Zufall, möchte ich sagen. Ja, es gibt ja die Einheit der Lichtjahre
und ein Lichtjahr ist zufällig ziemlich genau 9,46 Billionen Kilometer lang.
Also Wasser war 9,2, Lichtjahr ist 9,4 oder 9,5 Billionen Kilometer.
Also ziemlich genau das gleiche, kann man sagen.
Ja, soweit schert kein Verbrennermotor.
Ein Liter Wasser aufgereiht ist ein Lichtjahr Distanz.
So, und mit diesen zwei Gedanken, wir kriegen nicht mal eine Schneeflocke prognostiziert.
Also einen Tropfen Wasser, der mit Wind und Temperatur in Verhältnis gesetzt
wird, kriegen wir nicht berechnet.
Ein Liter Wasser, also nur H2O-Moleküle, super simpel eigentlich im Vergleich
zu, was man noch so an Molekülen ins Zusammenspiel bringen kann,
Ein Lichtjahr-Material, das in eine theoretische Gleichung müsste,
wollte man es berechnen.
Statt experimentell einfacher, da machen wir mal etwas mit dem Gliederwasser und gucken mal.
So, und unter diesen zwei Gesichtspunkten gehen wir jetzt in den Salon und lesen
dieses Schalmers Buch. Bis gleich.
Bis gleich.